hola bienvenidos a la clase básica de
sumas tal vez me dirán oye eso de sumar
apenas lo estoy aprendiendo cómo puede
ser tan básico y sin embargo van a ver
que conforme pase el tiempo poco a poco
esto se va a ser mucho más sencillo para
ustedes ya verán lo prometo vamos con un
clásico uno más uno
si yo quisiera saber cuánto es esto me
gustaría pensar en tal vez que tengo un
limón
y tú llegas y me regalas otro limón
entonces un limón más un limón cuánto
será tenemos 12 11 es igual a 2
poco a poco ustedes van a irse
aprendiendo todo esto sin embargo esta
es una buena forma de irnos aprendiendo
las sumas básicas vamos a hacer otra un
poquito más compleja
pensemos cuánto es 3 + 4
se pone interesante no ya no está tan
sencillo sin embargo podemos hacer otra
vez
digamos mis limones 1 2 3
yo tengo tres limones y digamos que tú
me regalas cuatro guayabas entonces
éstas serán amarillas una dos tres
4 si yo quisiera saber cuántas frutas en
total tengo vamos a hacer la sumatoria
una vez más vamos a contar los 1 2 3 4 5
7 eso significa que ahora tengo 7 frutas
34 es igual a 7 pero también hay otra
forma en la que podemos hacer las sumas
y esta es a través de una línea
en la que sumaremos en la que el 0 será
nuestro inicio y ahí pondremos todos los
números uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve diez
11-12 13-14
y de hecho puse una flecha indicando que
esto se puede ir as lejos lejos lejos
puede poner todos los números que yo
crea posibles o que se me ocurran si
regresamos a este ejercicio tomaremos
que empezamos en 3
3 es el 3 y vamos a sumar 4 a la hora de
sumar lo que vamos a hacer es recorrer
nos de uno en uno hacia la derecha esto
por qué porque hacia la derecha se están
incrementando nuestros números se hacen
más grandes ok entonces tenemos tres
iniciamos en el 3 y vamos a sumar 4 es
decir nos vamos a desplazar 4 veces
hacia la derecha contemos 1 2 3
4 y llegamos justo al 7 se dan cuenta
este 7 es nuestra respuesta entonces eso
indica que hicimos bastante bien nuestro
ejercicio hagamos un ejemplo más que les
parece cuánto es 8 + 1
aprovechando que nos quedó muy bonita
nuestra gráfica vamos a utilizarla de
nuevo les parece bien
empecemos nos vamos al número 8
y vamos a sumar 18 + 1 llegamos al 9 se
dan cuenta poco a poco estos números nos
van a ir aprendiendo sin embargo podemos
hacer tal vez un ejercicio más
complicado se avientan
cuánto es 5 más
y digo complicado porque necesitaríamos
muchísimos dedos en las manos para poder
completar esto tal vez incluso más de
los que tenemos lo que sí podemos hacer
es utilizar una vez más nuestra línea
por este momento no le hagan caso a
estas a estos ejercicios previos vamos a
utilizar un color distinto vamos a usar
un verde nos vamos al número 5 y aquí es
donde vamos a empezar y vamos a sumar 6
veces vamos a ir 1 2 3
56 llegamos al número 11 ahora lo
interesante con lo que yo quisiera
preguntarles es qué sucede si ahora
tengo 6 + 5 vamos a poner las cosas un
poquito más difíciles será 6 5 lo mismo
que arriba lo que estamos haciendo es
invertir los números antes tenía 56
ahora tengo 65 vamos a hacerlo por abajo
para que tengamos mayor facilidad de
verlo empezaremos en el número 6 me
alcanzan a ver aquí seis y nos
recorreremos cinco lugares hacia la
derecha
empezamos uno dos tres cuatro
5 volvimos a llegar al número 11 que
habíamos llegado hace un momento eso que
va a significar que
56 tenemos 11 y 65 tenemos 11 ustedes
pueden hacer varios intentos con
diferentes números y se van a dar cuenta
que siempre funciona siempre siempre
funciona igual no importa si tenemos el
5 primero o el 5 después mientras
tengamos las mismas cifras el 5 más el 6
la suma de esos va a ser siempre la
misma vamos a hacer una más 8 más 7
utilizaremos una gráfica nueva y
volvemos a hacer nuestra línea y
empezamos del 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7-8 9-10 seguimos un poco más porque al
parecer este será un número bastante
grande
14 15 16 17
nos vamos al 8 y le sumamos 7 lugares
hacia la derecha 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7
esto nos suma 15 quieren hacer la
comprobación de la vez pasada 7 + 8
empezaremos ahora en el 7 y lo haremos
por abajo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 volvimos a
llegar al 15 creo que con esto ya tienen
una idea bastante general de cómo sumar
ustedes pueden seguir haciendo los
ejercicios tanto con la fruta o
directamente con la línea poco a poco se
van a dar cuenta que esto es muy
sencillo estaría genial si en este
momento recuerdan que están sintiendo
qué emociones están sintiendo si se les
está siendo complicado fácil y en un
futuro regreso en este mismo vídeo y se
den cuenta que realmente era muy
sencillo nos vemos más adelante en los
siguientes vídeos bye